Chris you have an excellent scene and
goodbye promise
what impact has the film had on you and
what impact do you think goodbye promise
we'll have another um I guess one of the
impacts it's you know that had on me as
you don't what is the breaking point for
me when is the point where I say when
and you know I I don't put myself
through this torture anymore trying to
be an actor um and so in some ways I
think it it makes me think of that if
there is a point where i would say when
but you know if there is a point you
know I don't think I've reached it but
um but I guess you're certain things you
know I'm sure there's other careers
outside of being an actor but the acting
is the only thing I can think of right
now just because that's that's all is
sometimes it's like when people have
something that they're really really
trying to do and it could be easy for
them to do something else and be a
success in somebody else's mine I guess
it's it's I don't think people get
sometimes why they have to keep on doing
what they're doing meeting me their head
against the wall this wall that's in
front of them why right to the left or
like an open door but they're quite
certain if they hit their head against
this wall enough that that wall will
come down I I think maybe people really
get and maybe understand and take step
back that there is some you know that
some things some careers or some other
things that make people tick that they
just can't step away from and they can I
guess have an appreciation for how they
may be how hard they work at it or why
they have to do what they do so I think
hopefully some people will at least get
that
did you have any epiphanies after you
saw goodbye promise and something a
light wall go off or was it a
confirmation of what you're already hmm
that's a little bit of a of a
confirmation I mean you know without
talking too much of the ending it's like
it's interesting I was um you always you
always wondered what dumb what what
Gregor did at the end and if you did go
to that audition and I guess if for me I
guess in the end of my mind is like
always choose the audition and life I
mean I just that's the only thing I mean
it's not even a question its license if
there is always always always choose the
audition and you know it's the only way
I live that's the only thing I know you
know there's gonna be other things that
come up but you have to always choose
the audition
you